[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى الشخلي
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من نيويورك وتحديدا
من مبنى الامم المتحده حيث قال المدير
العام لمنظمه الامم المتحده للهجره ان
اكثر من 400 طالب لجوء لقوا حثهم اثناء
عبور البحر المتوسط خلال الثلث الاول من
العام الحالي
والى موسكو حيث يعتبر
نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي انا الحديث عن
وثائق امريكيه سريه مسربه قد يكون جانبا
من حمله تضليل امريكيه هدفها خداع روسيا
من البيت الابيض جدد منسقه لاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي رسائل طمانه وشرح من واشنطن
للحلفاء بشان الوثائق الاس
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
وسط التصاعد توتر بشان تايوان الرئيس
الصيني يدعو الجيش الى تعزيز التدريب من
اجل قتال فعلي بيجين تفرض منطقه حظر جوي
شماله تايوان الاحد بسبب ما سمتها انشطه
فضائيه تقارير استخباريه امريكيات تفيد
باعتزام الصين ضمه تايوان بعد اربع سنوات
[موسيقى]
مع زياده المخاوف من تداعيات تسريب وثائق
سريه للاستخبارات الامريكيه واشنطن تكفف
الاتصالات الدبلوماسيه لطمانه الحلفاء
البيت الابيض يعتبر التسريب انتهاكا لقدره
الولايات المتحده على حمايه المعلومات
وموسكو تتحدث عن حمله تضليل امريكيه
محتمله مرتبطه بالوثائق المسربه
معارك عنيفه في الجبهات الشرقيه من
اوكرانيا واشنطن تقول تتاهب لشن هجوم مضاد
واسع النطاق وكاميرا الجزيره في الميدان
ترصد دور سلاح الجو في جبهات القتال في
اوكرانيا لقطات خاصه لغارات الثياب على
مواقع روسيه في جبهه بخموت
وفي لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا تصاعد السجال المصري
الاثيوبي حول سد النهضه ادي سبب تقول انها
ليست بحاجه الى اذن لتعبئه رابعه للسد
بينما تحذر مصر من كون سد النهضه يمثل
ضغطا على مواردها المائيه لاستطلاع ارائكم
بهذا الشان كنا طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
ما هي توقعاتكم لمسار ازمه سد النهضه
الاجابات جاءت على الشكل التالي نحو 27%
صوتوا لصالح خيار تسويه بين الاطراف بينما
راى نحو 20% ان المسار هو نقل الملف الى
الامم المتحده حين قال 53% ان هناك مسارات
اخرى لتصعيد الازمه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الذي يظهر الان على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا
كما تتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
في الحلقه الاحدث لماساه طالبين اللجوء
وفاه عشره اشخاص جراء غرق قارب قباله تونس
[موسيقى]
يجهزهم لامر ما يحث الرئيس الصيني هؤلاء
وغيرهم من الجنود على تحسين قدراتهم من
اجل قتال فعلي يريد شجيم بينك من جيشه
التاهب دوما للدفاع عن سياده الصين
الاقليميه وحقوقها البحريه لا ضير في ذلك
كله لولا ان ظرف مرتبط اشد الارتباط
بتايوان
التي تعد الجزيره المتمتعه بحكم ذاتي جزءا
من اراضيها ترفض اي مسعا منها للانفصال
والاستقلال
بعد مناورتهم العسكريه الاخيره التي حاكت
تطويقه تايوان بالكامل يستعد الصينيون
بفرض حظر جوي على شمال الجزيره صباح الاحد
المقبل لمده نصف ساعه
هذه منطقه حظر طيران اقامتها الصين تقع
داخل منطقه تحديد الدفاع الجوي انها تبعد
حوالي 85 ميلا بحريا شمال تايوان
ينبه التايوانيون الى ان اي حظر للطيران
في اجوائهم سيسبب ما يصفونها بمخاطر جسيمه
للملاحه الجويه في المنطقه
وتلفت وزاره دفاعهم النظر الى مخاطر من
نوع اخر فقد تعقبت كما قالت 35 طائره
عسكريه صينيه في محيط تايوان يبدو ان على
تايوان ان تخشى ما هو اكثر من ذلك واخطر
لن اهون من شان طموح الصين الى الهيمنه
على تايوان ولكن تقديراتنا تفيد القياده
الصينيه تخامرها شكوك في امكانيه غزو
الجزيره من دون ان تدفع ثمنا باهضا نعم
امر الرئيس الصيني الجيش بالاستعداد لغزو
تايوان بحلول سنه 2007
ولكن هذا لا يعني بالضروره وقوع حرب بحلول
تلك السنه او ما يليها
الى تقارير استخباريه امريكيه تفيد
باعتزام الصين ضمه تايوان بعد اربع سنوات
من الان مع ذلك لا تجد واشنطن داعيا
لتصعيد الموقف يقول وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي
ان هدف بلاده هو السلام والامن والاستقرار
وخلق فرص وليس الدخول في حرب بارده جديده
ولا احتواء الصين والصين هي من يهدد
بالحرب تقول تايوان تايوان التي تؤكد
استعدادها للدفاع عن نفسها ترد الصين
بالقول ان السلطات الحزب الديمقراطي
الحاكم في تايوان مستعده لتحويل الجزيره
الى برميل بارود في رساله تتعدى تايوان
الى الاقليم تذكر بيجين من تسميها بعض
الدول بانه ليس بامكان القوات الاجنبيه
حمايتها بل انها كما تضيف ستفاقم التوتره
وتجلب لنفسها الكوارث
وتاتي الخطوه الصينيه في مناطق تتقاطع
فيها العديد من المسارات الدوليه وتثير
اسئله بشان ما تعرف بمنطقه تحديدا دفاع
جوي بين تايوان والصين نتعرف على طبيعه
هذه المنطقه وعن حالات التوغل الصيني التي
شهدتها في السنتين الاخيرتين
بعد جدل زياره الرئيسه مجلس النواب
الامريكي السابق نانسيبلوس الى تايوان برز
الى الواجهه حديث عن المجال الجوي وتحديدا
ما يعرف بالخط الاوسط ومنطقه تحديد الدفاع
الجوي بين تايوان والصين فاذا كان لكل
دوله مجال جوي مدني تتحكم فيه بالطائرات
المدنيه التي تدخله ويعبر عنه بالمجال
الجوي المدني فلهذه الدول ما يعرف بمنطقه
تحديد الدفاع الجوي وتكون اكبر من المجال
الجوي المدني وتتيح الفرصه للدوله للتعرف
على اي طيران حربي يقترب من حدودها الصين
اعلنت حضره طيران شمل طيران في وقت قالت
فيه وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه انها تعقبت
35 طائره عسكريه صينيه في محيط الجزيره
منطقه حظر طيران التي تتحدث عنها بيجين
تقع على بعد 85 ميلا بحريا شمل تايوان اين
نحو 157 كيلومترا والاغلاق وفق سيكون ضمن
منطقه تحديد الدفاع الجوي للجزيره سيؤثر
ذلك فيما بين 60 و70% من الرحلات الجويه
بين الشمال شرق اسيا وجنوب شرق اسيا وكذلك
الرحلات الجويه بين تايوان وكوريا
الجنوبيه واليابان وامريكا الشماليه في
2021 سجل التايوان نحو الف عمليه التوغل
لطائره حربيه صينيه في الجهه الجنوبيه
الغربيه لمنطقه تحديد الدفاع الجوي وهو
اكثر من ضعف ما سجل في 2020 الجدل القائم
سلطه الضوء ايضا على ما يعرف بالخط الاوسط
وهو حدود غير رسميه وضعت خلال الحرب
البارده يلتزم بها الى حد كبير وتمتد على
طول منتصف المضيق الفاصل بين تايوان
والصين على مدى العامين الماضيين اعلن
المسؤولون الصينيون ان الخط الاوسط من
وجهه نظرهم غير موجود وسجل كمثال تجاوز
للخط من طائره وسفن حربيه صينيه خلال
مناورات عسكريه في اغسطس من العام الماضي
معركه الحدود الجويه تاتي بينما اشارت
اوبيسي جروب وهي شركه متخصصه في مجال
النقل الجوي ومخاطر الطيران الى ان قيودا
سابقه على الطيران ادت الى اضطرابات كبيره
في الرحله الجويه بالمنطقه واضطرت بعض
الطيارين الى حمل وقود اضافي
اما وزير الخارجيه الامريكي فقال ان اعمال
اكراهن وسلوكا خطيرا تتم ملاحظتها في بحر
جنوب الصين واكد تمسك بلاده بالتزاماتها
تجاهها حلفائها اصلا وخلال لقاء جمعه
بالضباط بالضبط المسؤول عن وزاره الدفاع
الوطني الفلبينيه قال انه يشدد على ضروره
تعزيز القدرات العسكريه والتطوير
التحالفات والدفاعات السبرانيه لحمايه
البنيه التحتيه وتعزيز التبادل
الاستخباراتي للتصدي بشكل افضل للتحديات
وينضم الان الينا من بيجن دين لونج استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه شنهاي ومن
واشنطن الادميرال وليم فعلا القائد السابق
للقياده الوسطى الامريكيه والرئيس قسم
الصين في المعهد الدولي للدراسه
الدبلوماسيه بجامعه جورج تاون شكرا جزيلا
على وجودكم معنا في الحصاد وابدا معك
سيدنج اذا
التوجه لفرض حظر الطيران في منطقه حساسه
جدا في وقت حرج جدا
بالون اختبار ام اكثر
ان
منوعات الصينيه ترسل يعني رسائل قويه
لنزهه الانفصال
في جزيره تايوان وقوات الخارجيه التي يعني
تستفز الصين في هذا المنطقه
ونقطه ثانيه ان السيد
ما يسمى
بعمليات العسكريه
الى تحرير حيوان
العمليات يعني لها مخزن
خاصا
لانه
يعني
هل
قضيه الحيوان في المستقبل
عبر يعني حلول عسكريه
وانتم تتابعون بلا شك ما يجري من الجانب
الصيني هذه الخطوه اذا ما اقدمت عليها
الصين بالفعل
ما المرجح ان يكون رد فعل واشنط
انا لم اشهد اسمع التفاصيل هذا المقترح
ولكن اراه ان هذا هذا هذا يعني عمل عسكري
كبير وهذه منطقه حساسه جدا وفيها توترات
كثيره بين الولايات المتحده
والصين وحول التايوان ويبدو لان في هذا
الوقت ينبغي ان نقوم بعكس ذلك اي تخفيف
النشاطات العسكريه وتخفيف الخطاب
العسكري والعوده الى محاوله
الطريق حل للمستقبل الولايات المتحده لم
تغير سياساتها ازاءه تايوان واعتقد
ان هذه النشاطات العسكريه المتزايده هي
مجرد فرصه لارتكاب اخطاء
وتبعات ذلك قد تكون شديده وبالتالي
فرسالتي هي علينا ان نوقف هذا
التحركات العسكريه تقوم بها الصين
ولكي ناخذ ننهي اي فرصه اخطاء تقع دون عمل
قصد وتقول يجب التخفيس من التحركات
العسكريه ولكن ايضا الخطابات اخر ما صرح
به ويليام من الاستخبارات الامريكيه عن
وجود معلومات استخباراتيه تتحدث عن
استعداد لغزو الصين في 2027 ولكن قال انه
لا يرجح ذلك اذا كان الامر كذلك ما الحاجه
اصلا
مثل هذا التصريح برايك
ليس لدي اي فكره عن سببه لكن هذا نوع
الكلام الذي لا يساعد اطلاقا هذا مجرد
يثير شده الخطاب والابره
ويحفز وينشط السياسيين ويزعج الجميع ولا
ينبغي ان نقدم مثل هذه التسرعات بل علينا
ان نعود الى النقاشات ونحن نتطلع الى
المستقبل
وانا ايضا اود ان نلاحظ هنا ايضا ان هناك
زياده كبيره في مستوى التحركات العسكريه
قامت بها الصين لم تؤثر فقط على العلاقات
بين الصين والولايات المتحده بل ايضا على
كل الدول المنطقه وهذا في رايه هو السبب
الرئيسي
لعملهم بتعاون اكبر لانهم يشعرون
بالقلق هذه الروح العسكريه تبديها الصين
وتزيدها شهرا بعد اخر وبالتالي اعتقد انا
على الصين ان تعيد الن ظر فيما تقوم به
ودعونا نعود الى وضع اكثر طبيعيه
واعتياديه
هل هناك اي مؤشر يدل على ان الصين يمكن ان
تخفض من حده التصعيد وخصوصا على ضوء
التصريحات الاخيره لبرنس كيف تستقبل صينيا
الولايات المتحده يعني
تخفف من
[موسيقى]
على سعيد لما يسمى
بالعلاقات
المتحده
اعتقد ان يعني هناك
استفزازات كبيره خلال الايام الماضيه لدى
زيارتها
للولايات المتحده
ولقاء مع رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
كله
افعال صينيه
العسكريه الصينيه
تاتي كرد فعلي
ما قامت من زياره
الولايات المتحده وايضا
توجه سيدنا القويه
للولايات المتحده لان يعني
شخصيه سياسيه بارزه امريكيه يعني قامت
لاقامه لقاء مع
وهذا
يخالف يعني
مبدا سن واحده
واتفق الجانبي الصيني الامريكي من اتفاقات
يعني
اقامه الع لاقات بينهما اشكرك من بيجين
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه شانهاي
واشكر الادم فعلا القائد السابق لقياده
الوسطى الامريكيه ورئيس قسم الصين في
المعهد الدولي للدراسات الدبلوماسيه في
جامعه جورج تاون شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
قلى منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كاربي في لقاء
مع شبكه فوكس نيوز ان واشنطن تحاول ان
تشرح لحلفائها ما حدث بشان المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه المسربه الخاصه بالحرب في
اوكرانيا مشيرا الى ان التحقيقات لم تظهر
الكثير بعد
هناك وجود عسكري امريكي صغير في السفاره
بالارتباط مع مكتب الملحق العسكري
لمساعدتنا في العمل على المحاسبه فيما يخص
المواد الخاصه باوكرانيا فهم مرتبطون بتلك
السفاره وبمكتب الملحق العسكري
وبدوره قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي
تاخذ قضيه تسريب الوثائق السريه على محمل
الجد واضاف انه يعقد لقاءات اليوميه مع
قاده عسكريين كبار لمتابعه القضيه
قال وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه
ان وثائق البانتاجون المسربه بخصوص هجوم
اوكرانيا المضاد تشكل مزيجا من الحقيقه
والكذب واضاف ان تسريب بيانات السريه هو
تصرف روسي متعمد لتقليل الثقه بين
الولايات المتحده وشركائها
امائئب وزير الخارجيه الروسي فقال ان
موسكو ليس لديها اي موقف بشان مساله تسريب
وثائق البانتاغون السريه لكنها لا تستبعد
ان يتم استخدامه معلومات كاذبه بهدف تضليل
روسيا وفق تعبيره
هذا وكانت رويترز نقلت في وقت سابق عن
مسؤولين امريكيين ان التحقيق جاري لمعرفه
كيفيه ودوافع تسريب الوثائق مع عدم
استبعاد مسؤوليه افراد موالينا لروسيا عن
التسريب
طبعا هذا الاختراق الاخير للوثائق
الامريكيه يعتبر الاكبر منذ تسريب
المتعاقد السابق مع وكاله الامن القومي
ادولد سنودن مئات الاف الوثائق السريه عام
2013 فواشي يبدو انها مصابه
بمتلازمه التسريب كما ان موسكو هي المشتبه
فيه هي الدائم بالاختراق
الى روسيا تشير اصابع الاتهام بشان عمليه
التسريب الاخيره للوثائق العسكريه وثائق
مبهوره بعباره سري للغايه تتعلق بالامن
القومي الامريكي والشرق الاوسط ومنطقه
اسيا وفي موسكو استخفاف بالاتهام وتقليل
منه اذ ان هناك اتجاها عاما لتحميل روسيا
مسؤوليه كل شيء يقول الكريم
لكن خطوره عمليه التسريب تتخطى السجال
السياسي فالتسريب هذا يعد الخرق الامني
الاخطر منذ ما كشفه المتعقد السابق مع
وكاله الامن القومي الامريكي
لعشره الاف الوثائق ومقاطع الفيديو
والبرقيات الدبلوماسيه عام 2013
وفي الحالتين تحضر روسيا متهما او مساندا
في افضل الاحوال من وجهه النظر الامريكيه
في يونيو حزيران عام 2013 سرب ادواردسن
مليونا
كشفت عن فضائح تجسس على مواطنين امريكيين
ومسؤولين اجانب بما في ذلك قاده دول حليفه
للولايات المتحده تورطت بها وكاله الامن
القومي والاستخبارات الامريكيه
سرب سنودن الوثائق اثناء وجوده في هونج
كونج التي غادرها متوجها الى روسيا على ان
ينتقل بعدها الى امريكا الجنوبيه
وخلال وجوده في موسكو الغت حكومه الولايات
المتحده جواز سفره فبقي في روسيا وطلب
اللجوء السياسي ليمنحه الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين في ايلول سبتمبر الماضي
الجنسيه الروسيه مع زوجته فيما اعتبر
اصرار الروسيا على ضمان امن الرجل
لماذا وفرت روسيا الحمايه لسنودن سؤال
يضعها في خانه المشتبه فيه والى ان تتكشف
ادله تثبت الاتهام او تنفيه فان وزاره
العدل الامريكيه بدات تحقيقا جديدا في
التسريبات الاخيره
العلاقه بين واشنطن وعمليات التسريب مزمنه
فقبل سنودن كان موقع ويكيليكس ومؤسسه
جوليا
في عام 2009 2010 نشر الموقع مئات الاف
الوثائق ومقاطع الفيديو المسربه من العراق
وافغانستان بما فجر فضيحه عن اخلاقيات
الجيش الامريكي وجنوده في مناطق القتال
ومنذ ذلك الحين بدا الصونش رحله الفرار
واللجوء الى ان اخرجته الاكوادور من
سفارتها في لندن وسلمته للسلطات
البريطانيه
وينضم الان الينا من ولايه مين
عضو مجلس الامن القومي الامريكيه السابق
اهلا وسهلا بك سيد ادمز في الحصاد اذا
الحديث عن متلازمه التسريب عندما يتعلق
الامر بالولايات المتحده
بلا شك يحدث ضرر كبير استمعه الولايات
المتحده وقدرتها على حمايه المعلومات ما
حجم الضرر هنا
ان الضرر في هذه الحاله بالذات على ارجاع
اقل ضررا من الضرر التي حصل في المساحات
السابقه مع سانج او سنودن
قضيه سنه
حول الحروب التي جرت في افغانستان والعراق
وسنودن ما اثاره كان اكثر ضرا او اقل اكثر
اهميه لانه في الحقيقه قطعت التفاصيل حول
بنيت وهيكلة التجسس في الولايات المتحده
وبالتالي هذه كانت حالتان مهمتان كبيرتان
اما هذه الحاله فهي قل اهميه لان الوثائق
لا تثبت اي شيء لم نعلم انك لم يحصل او او
لم تكشف اي شيء لا نعرف لكده تقريبا كل
موجود في التسريبات لحد الان هي امور كان
نعرفها من التقارير اما تفاصيل الجداول
وماذا الى ذلك فقد كشفت في هذه الوثائق
لكن في الواقع والحقيقه اننا المتحده
تتجسس على الدول الاخرى وكنا نعرف ايضا
بعض ذلك سيكون محرجا وايضا كنا نعرف ان
هناك الشحه او قلل في معداته الذخائر
الاوكرانيه وبالتالي اذا هذه الحقائق
حقيقه هي غريبه
وتعزز ما سبق ذكرناه في الاشهر الماضيه
حول اوكرانيا ولكن بشكل عام ليس لا تكشف
الامور كثيره كما حل كما هو حال الحالتين
السابقتين
اذا كان البساطه
شخص مثل رياض كوف
يتحد شيء مضلل من جانب الولايات المتحده
كيف تقرا هذا التصريح من رياضكم
المستحيل تماما لنعرف من اين جاءت هذه
التسريبات او مصدرها يمكن فقط ان نقدم
تخمينات
حول الضحايا في حرب بين اوكرانيا وروسيا
اما المعلومات الاخرى فكلها موجوده سابقا
ما هو صعب ان نفهمه هنا هو هذه التسريبات
هل انها تشكل فعلا جهدا تقامت به اما
روسيا او الولايات المتحده او احدهم احد
في اوكرانيا للتاثير على المشريات الحرب
لا اعتقد سيكون لها تاثير كبير على حرب
لكن ربما بعض التاثير هناك بعض هناك تاثير
على بعض العمليات الخاصه ولا نعرف ان كان
هذا صحيح ام لا هل افهم من كلامك ان
العمليه الان عمليه التسريب الان ليست
الضرر الخوف من المعلومات التي سربت وانما
الضرر الاكثر هو من التسريب المستمر هل
يمكن الق ول ذلك ان يستمر يعني عمليه
تسريب عمليه تسريب هذا هو الضرر الاكبر
هنا
اعتقد ان المشكله هنا هي ان هناك الكثير
دول
ضلعه في جهد الخاص بالحرب اوكرانيا عدا
روسيا واوكرانيا ولا حد قال بانه مقالات
مؤسسات اخرى وحكومات اخرى ربما قد شاركت
في هذا الامر لكن هناك الكثير من الايادي
في هذه المعلومات فهناك كثير من الاشياء
الجر التبادلها ومن الصعب معرفه اين
مصدرها ومن الصعب معرفه جزء من حمله
دعائيه سياسيه ام لا عن تحقيق او سيء بدات
تحقيق كبير للتاكيد لكن التاثيرات على
الحرب اقول استطيع اقول انها تغنيها حد
الادنى او قليل جدا اشكرك جولد ادم مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي السابق من ولايه
[موسيقى]
وعلى جبهات اوكرانيا نقلت وكاله
الانترفيكس عن وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قولها
ان قواتها تتصدت لوحده من احتياطيه الجيش
الاوكراني حاولت التوغل داخل باخمه في شرق
اوكرانيا وقالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قوات فاجنر سيطرت على ثلاث مناطق جديده في
باخمت كما اعلن المتحدث باسم الوزاره ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تكبدت خسائر كبيره في
عدد من الجبهات
حررت وحداته ثلاثه مناطق جديده في مخمه
خلال اليوم الماضي وقد قضي على نحو 245
عسكريا اوكرانيا في محور الدونيسك وعلى
180 في محورين
الجنوبيا وفي محور كرنسي ليمن قضي على 80
جنديا اوكرانيا ودمرت اربع مصفحات ومعدات
اخرى كما اسقطت خمس مسيرات اوكرانيه
وفي الجهه المقابله اعلنت هيئه الاركان
العامه الاوكرانيه صدق قواتها اكثر من 50
هجوما على محاور القتال شرقي اوكرانيا 20
منها باتجاه ضخمه واشارت هيئه الاركان الى
ان القوات الروسيه نفذت محاوله هجوم فاشله
على بلده بغداد شمال غربي بخمت كما اعلنت
الهيئه شن قوتها ثلاثه عشره غاره جويه
استهدفت مواقع لتمركز القوات الروسيه
اضافه الى قصف مواقع تحوي اسلحه ومعدات
واسقاط طائرتين مسيرتين
اكد وزير الدفاع الامريكي
لرئيس الوزراء الاوكراني درس ان الولايات
المتحده ستقدم الدعم العسكري للهجوم
المضاده المستمر لاوكرانيا ضد روسيا ما
دام الامر يتطلب ذلك واعرب اوستن عن الثقه
بقدره واشنطن على تلبيه احتياجات خلال فصل
الربيع الحالي وما بعده تصريحات اوستن
جاءت خلال مباحثاته في الفانتاجون مع رئيس
وزراء اوكرانيا
سنواصل تسليما المساعدات الامنيه بسرعه من
خلال عقود التسليح ومن مخزوننا الخاص نظل
ملتزمين بالاستدامه وضمان ان تتلقى القوات
الاوكرانيه قطع الغيار والتدريب على اعمال
الصيانه في الوقت نفسه سنواصل الاستثمار
في قاعدهنا الصناعيه الدفاعيه لتعزيز
الانتاج لذا اثق باننا سنلبي حاجات
اوكرانيا الدفاعيه خلال هذا الربيع وما
بعده
يشكل سلاح الجو احد ابرز معالم المعارك
المستمره على جبهات القتال في اوكرانيا اذ
تعلن القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه بشكل يومي
تنفيذها غارات جويه لمنع تقدم القوات
الروسيه لاسيما في الجبهه الشرقيه مراسل
الجزيره حسان مسعود رافق احدى المروحيات
الحربيه وحصلت الجزيره على لقطات حصريه
لغارات على مواقع روسيه في جبهه
مع طلوع كل شمس
مبكرا يبدا سلاح المروحيات الاوكراني
تنفيذ هجماته
في اخطر جبهات الحرب
هذه اللقطات التي وثقناها عبر تثبيت
كاميرات على جسم الطائره بموافقه طاقمها
ترصد تنفيذ غارات جويه
على عدد من مواقع القوات الروسيه
وتحصيناتها في محيط باخما
في محاوله لوقف تقدمها فالمروحيات تلعب
دورا مهما بالنسبه للجانب الاوكراني تناول
المروحيات بحذر شديد
فبعد كل ضربه تطلق القنابل الحراريه
لتقياها من الاستهداف بالصواريخ الروسيه
المضاده للطائرات ولتجنب مصير طائرات
اسقطت خلال المعارك بعد اتمام المهمه تعود
المروحيه الى منطقه اكثر امنا نسبيا تهبط
احداها هنا لتقلنا نحو احد مواقعها الخاصه
عبر ثمانيه صنع هذه نتوجه نحو قاعده جويه
مع فريق القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه للتعرف
على عملهم عن قرب
يحرص طاقم الطائره المؤلف من قائد ومساعد
ومهندس على اجراء مناورات مستمره اثناء
التحليق والبقاء على ارتفاع منخفض لا يزيد
عن 30 مترا لتجنب رصدها
نهبط في القاعده المستحدثه بعيدا عن
الانظار حيث يتمركز سرب من الطائرات
المروحيه المختلفه وتتم عمليات الصيانه
لطائرات باتت متقدمه في العمر
بعد كل غاره وقبل كل مهمه نقوم بالتحقق من
سلامه المروحيه وصيانتها بشكل فوري فهذه
الطائرات تحتاج لعنايه دائمه يتم تزويد
المروحيات بصواريخ جديده حيث تحمل 20 منها
في كل جانب ويكتب الجنود على بعضها رسائل
لاعدائهم
يوري صديقي قتل خلال المعارك ولا شيء يعوض
خسارته لكنني اتذكره بكتابه اسمه على هذه
الصواريخ التي سنضرب بها قتلته
قبل انطلاقه نحو مهمته القادمه يحدثنا
ايفان احد الطيارين الشبان ذو الثلاثين
عاما عن طبيعه عملياتهم واحتياجاتهم
ننفذ غارات مزدوجه بمروحيتين على الخط
الامامي لقوات العدو لاسناد القوات
الارضيه طورنا طائره اللوجستيه كهذه
للهجمات لكنها قديمه وقدراتها محدوده امام
امكانات العدو الجويه ونحتاج لطائرات
حديثه
وهكذا تكتمل الاستعدادات لتنفيذ مزيد من
الهجمات
نحو مهمه جديده قد تكون الاخيره بالنسبه
لهم تنطلق هذه المروحيات التابعه للقوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه في ظروف استثنائيه
شديده الخطوره لكن الاوكرانيين يرون ان
اهمتها بالنسبه لمعاركهم
تستحق المخاطره حسن مسعود الجزيره من احدى
قواعد القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه السريه
شرقيه اوكرانيا
ومن جهته دعا رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني
الولايات المتحده الى تزويد بلاده
بالطائرات الحربيه واكد حاجه بلاده الى
مزيد من الاسلحه الثقيله والمدرعات من اجل
انجاح هجومها المضاد تجاه الجيش الروسي
وفق تعذره
لكي ينجح هجومنا المضاد نحتاج الى مزيد من
هذه الاسلحه التفوق الجوي عامل حاسم في
الحرب الحديثه ولهذا السبب تبادر اوكرانيا
الى بناء تحالف جديد تحت مسمى تحالف
الطائره المقاتله ونوجه الدعوه للولايات
المتحده لكي تصبح اهم شريك يمكن لامريكا
ان تبرهن مجددا عن قيادتها من خلال تزويد
اوكرانيا بطائره اف 15
وانضم الان الينا من بيروت العميد الياس
حنا الخبيره العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا
وسهلا بك عميد الياس معنا في الحصاد اذا
الاوكرانيون في البدايه كانوا يقولون
نحتاج دبابات الان يقولون نحتاج طائرات
حربيه ما الذي يمكن ان يحسم فعلا الهجوم
المضاد الذي كثر وطال الحديث عنه ام ان
القضيه قضيه وقت واطاله وقت اكثر من اي
شيء
اخر
ليلى منظومه الهجوم العكسي او الكاونتر
يلي يحضر له هو من ضمن مجموعه ومنظومه
يعني الدبابه لا تعمل لوحدها الاليه
المدرعه تحمل العسكر وهذه الاليه والدبابه
يلزمها دعم ناري من مدفعيه وبالتالي
يستلزم ايضا منع الطيران الروسي من
الاستعمال واتى في التقرير موضوع الطائرات
الطوافه لدعم الجبهات الاماميه فاذا انت
امام منظومه كامله متكامله ايضا هي بحاجه
لاستخبارات واستعلام تكتي كي تنجح اليوم
يجري في مخموت هو استهلاك للقوى الروسيه
من جهه والاوكرانيه من جهه واليوم عندما
نفكر في الحرب ليلى لا يمكن لنا ان نستبعد
ما اتى في هذه الوثائق وثائق بغض النظر عن
صحتها او سلبيتها او ايجابياتها اغلب ما
ورد فيها هو موجود كان يقوله وزير الدفاع
الامريكي
ما الذي انت لمسته في هذه الوثائق الذي
يمكن ان يؤثر على الحرب في المدى القصير
خطوره الوثائق اذا كانت صحيحه هي مده
اللايف يعني المده بين حصولها ونشرها او
تسريبها اربعين يوم هي تعكس الحاله
للجيشين الخلق الامريكي العميق للجيش
الروسي
لمخططاته واهدافه ووضعه وايضا يصف الجيش
الاوكراني على ان اي هجوم عكسي لم يعطي
النتائج المطلوبه والاتجاه العام هو نحو
ستيلميت او ما يسمى بالاستنزاف المشترك
فلنسلم جدلا الليله سقطت بخموت بعدها ماذا
هل نذهب الى كراماتورسكو وهي اكثر بعشر او
15 مره من مخموت او نذهب الى سلوبيان فاذا
نحن امام مرحله من الانتحار المشترك بين
القوتين فاذا نحن امام الحديث مثلا عن
حمايه الحمايه الجويه
98% من الحمايه الجويه الاوكرانيه هي سلاح
من اصل سوفياتي للسلاح الاوكراني هي ليست
امريكيه وليست غربيه لانه القصف العنيف
والصواريخ والمسيرات لا يمكن لما اعطي من
سلاح غربي مضاد للطيران ومضاد للصواريخ ان
يكفي لهذا العدد طيب في قضيه الوقت هنا
وهنا اعود لسؤالي الاول يعني قضيه ان تطول
ان يطول امد الحرب وان الولايات المتحده
تظل تدعم بالاسلحه وهي مستعده لتحارب حتى
اخر جندي اوكراني كما يقال في الاعلام
الامريكي بينما الرئيس بوتين لا يمكن ان
يخسر لانه يعرف ان خسارته تعني نهايته في
وسط هذين الموقفين يعني ما هو مصير الحرب
على الارض ما هو مصير اوكرانيا بين هاتين
القوتين
المؤشرات التكتيكيه على الارض ليلى وهذا
نشرته مجله وجريده
هو
التحصينات
الكثيفه والمكثفه حول القرم وحول خط خرسون
او نهر النيبر
وزاروجيا لحمايه ميليتو بول وكانه يقال
بالمرحله القادمه هي مرحله الثبات في مكان
الانتهاء من مخبوط وقد تقف المعركه في
مكان ما وفلهم فلنا الى طاوله المفاوضات
وتبدا الخبل للقصه كما حصل في بالعامه 52
في في
كوريا بالحرب الكوريه فاذا هذه التحصينات
لماذا لمنع الهجوم والهجوم في مكان اخر
وكاننا نذهب الى ما يسمى بتحقيق بما توفر
والبقاء عند هذا الامر
شكرا جزيلا لك العميد الياس حنا من بيروت
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها اجرت امس
الثلاثاء اختبارا ناجحا لاطلاق صاروخ
باليستي عابر للقارات واوضحت الوزاره ان
الهدف من العمليه هو اختبار المعدات
القتاليه المتقدمه للصواريخ الباليستيه
وقد اشارت موسكو الى انها اخطرت واشنطن
بالعمليه
[موسيقى]
وفي مزيد عن الاخبار عبر العالم اكد وزير
الدوله في الخارجيه الاثيوبيه ميزكانو
ارجا ان محاولاتي مصر تسييسه ملفي سد
النهضه لن تفيد اي طرف جاء ذلك خلال لقائه
مع رئيس المفوضيه الافريقيه موسى فكي
وقالت الخارجيه ان اركا اوضح ان اثيوبيا
لديها موقف ثابت بضروره استمرار المفاوضات
الثلاثيه تحت رعايه الاتحاد الافريقي
ونقلت الخارجيه الاثيوبيه عن فك قوله ان
الاتحاد الافريقي يعتقد بوجوب ان يكون ملف
النيل ضمن الاجنده الافريقيه وقال بيان
لمكتب رئيس المفاوضات الافريقيه ناموسفيكي
التقى ايضا مندوبه مصر الدائم في الاتحاد
الافريقي محمد جاد
ومن جانبه قلل المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الاثيوبيه ملا السالم ان بلاده تعمل
لاجراء مفاوضات ثلاثيه مع مصر والسودان
تعود بالفائده على الجميع بشان حل الخلاف
حول السد وفي المقابل شدد المتحدث
الاثيوبي على ان بلاده لا تحتاج الى اذن
من احد لتعبئه سد النهضه مؤكدا الالتزام
اثيوبيا بحل القضيه داخل البيت الافريقي
[موسيقى]
شرحنا من قبل بان اثيوبيا لا تحتاج الى
اذن لاجراء التعبئه وسد النهضه لن يلحق
الضرر بمصر والسودان وهم يعرفون ذلك
تزامنا مع اي تعبئه تشن علينا حمله لتشويه
صورتنا واظهارنا باننا دوله لا تحترم
القوانين الدوليه وهذه طريقه لصرف الانظار
عن الاوضاع السياسيه الداخليه لديهم
اثيوبيا ملتزمه بحل القضيه داخل البيت
الافريقي
استنكر حمدي لوزه النائب وزير الخارجيه
المصريه اتهام اثيوبيا لبلاده بتسييس ملف
النيل واكد ان استمرار المفاوضات لعشر
سنوات دون نتائج دليل على التعنت الاثيوبي
بحسب وصفه وقال لوزه ان الخشيه من تداعيات
مشروع سد النهضه على الامن المائيه
المصريه حقيقيه وتستند الى دراسات علميه
موثوقه واضاف ان الادعاء الاثيوبيه
المستمر بتسييس مصر لقضيه سد النهضه هو
محاوله للتنصل من المسؤوليه القانونيه
بحسب تعبيره
قلى مصدر عسكري سوداني لقوات الدعم السريع
حركت قوات ضخمه دون اخطار الجيش وتم
استدعاء قوات من مناطق اخرى
لمواجهه الموقف في مروي وقال المصدر ان
القوات المسلحه طالبت قوات الدعم السريع
بالانسحاب من منطقه تمركزها الجديد في
مروي وانها وان لم تفعل فسيتم اجبارها على
ذلك وكان مصدر مطلع في حكومه الولايه
الشماليه في السودان قال ان حكومه الولايه
فوجئت بانتشار نحو 100 سياره نقل عسكريه
تابعه لقوات الدعم السريع بالقرب من مطار
مروه دون اي تنسيق مسبق مع سلطات الولايه
وفي المقابل قال مكتب الناطق الرسمي باسم
قوات الدعم السريع ان بعض وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي تناقلت ما سماها مزاعم بان قوات
الدعم السريع قامت باعمال حربيه تجاه مطار
مروي واضاف المكتب في بيان ان قوات الدعم
السريع قوات قوميه تعمل في اطار القانون
بالتنسيق والتناغم التام مع قياده القوات
المسلحه وبقيه القوات النظاميه الاخرى
واضافه انا وجودها في الولايه الشماليه
وفي مدينه مروي ياتي ضمن وجودها في بقيه
الولايات وذلك في اطار تاديه مهامها
وواجباتها التي تمتد حتى الصحراء ودعت
قوات الدعم السريع جميع المواطنين ووسائل
الاعلام الى عدم الانسياق وراء ما وصفتها
بالمعلومات الكاذبه التي تهدف الى اشاعه
الفتنه وتقويض امن واستقرار الوطن بح سب
البيان
وانضم الان الينا من الخرطوم مراسل
الجزيره اسامه سيد احمد اهلا بك اسامه في
الحصاد اذا ما هي حقيقه هذه التحركات
المنسوبه لقوات الدعم السريع ما الذي حصل
اليوم
نعم يعني خلال الساعات الماضيه تحدثنا الى
مصادر رسميه في حكومه الولايه الشماليه
واكدت لنا هذه المصادر بالفعل ان هناك
ارتال من السيارات المدججه بالسلاح واعداد
كبيره من الجنود التابعين الى تابعينا
لقوات الدعم السريع ووصلت بالفعل الى
منطقه مروي في الولايه الشماليه
بحسب المصادر التي تحدثنا اليها المصادر
الرسميه التي تحدثنا اليها اكدت ان والي
الولايه الشماليه تراس اجتماعا لليله
الامن في الولايه الشماليه يعني لبحث هذه
التطورات خاصه وان هذه الخطوه التي قامت
بها قوات الدعم السريع بوصول هذه الارتال
الى منطقه
مروي بحسب المصادر الرسميه في الولايه
الشماليه ان هذه الخطوه لم تتم بتنسيق مع
الجهات الرسميه الحكوميه في الولايه
الشماليه
ولا حتى التنسيق مع الجهات العسكريه في
هذه في الولايه الشماليه ما حدا بهذا
الاجتماع للتوجيه لارسال رساله الى رئيس
مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان القائد
العام للجيش السوداني
لنقل خلال هذه الرساله لنقل يعني عدم
الارتياح
والذي لازم الاهالي نتيجه وصول اعداد
كبيره من القوات الدعم السريع وتمركوزها
قرب مطار مروي في الولايه الشماليه ولكن
ربما هذه الخطوه لاحقا خرجت قوات الدعم
السريعه قبل يعني ساعه تقريبا ببيان اكدت
فيه ان هذه الخطوه وصول يعني اعداد من من
سيارات المدجدجه بالسلاح واعداد من الجنود
الى منطقه مروي لا يخرج من كونه انتشار
ايوه عادي كبقيه الانتشار ببقيه الانتشار
في بقيه الولايات وهي بذلك تهدف الى
الوصول الى عده اهداف من هذا الانتشار في
هذه المنطقه خاصه محاربه الجريمه العابره
كما ذكر البيان وكذلك محاربه انتشار
السلاح وكذلك قالت ان هذه الخطوه تهدف الى
يعني محاربه هذه ما سمتها الظواهر السالبه
وحذرت مما سمته يعني وسائل الفتنه
والاخبار الكاذبه وقالت انها ستلاحظ
ذلك شكرا جزيلا لك
ادركنا الوقت اسامه سيد احمد شكرا على كل
هذه المعلومات وسنتابع بلا شك الملف
[موسيقى]
عوده الان الى التطور الاحدث في مسلسل او
بالاحرم ماساه طالبي اللجوء نتحدث عن
انتشال جثث عشره من طالبي لجوء اثراء غرق
مركبه قباله سواحل شرق تونس ماذا حدث تقول
السلطات التونسيه انهم انطلقوا من سواحل
محافظه صفاقس على متن قارب خشبي من الحجم
الكبير وكانوا في اتجاه السواحل الاوروبيه
ليس الحدث هو الاول فقد ارتفعت وتيره
محاولات عبور البحر الابيض المتوسط من قبل
طالبي لجوء متجهين نحو السواحل الايطاليه
بشكل لافت في الفتره الاخيره مع تحسن
احوال الطقس
تسجل تونس التي تبعد بعض سواحلها اقل من
150 كيلومترا عن جزيره لمبيدوسا الايطاليه
محاولات متكرره من طالبي لجوء ينحدر
معظمهم من دول افريقيا جنوب الصحراء وقد
لقي اربعه طالبي لجوء من افريقيا جنوب
الصحراء حتفهم وفقد 23 في حديثي غرق
الجمعه والسبت قباله سواحل تونس في حين تم
انقاذ 53 اخرين
في السادس والعشرين من مارس ان تشلت جثث
طالبه لجوء من افريقيا جنوب الصحراء اثراء
غرق ثلاثه قوارب قباله سواحل تونس وتم
انقاذه 11 شخصا
يقول الحرس الوطني التونسيين اكثر من 14
الف طالب لجوء معظمهم من افريقيا جنوب
الصحراء تم اعتراضهم او انقاذهم في الاشهر
الثلاثه الاولى من العام الحالي وذلك
اثناء محاولاتهم العبور الى اوروبا اي
خمسه اضعاف الارقام المسجله في الفتره
نفسها من العام الماضي القلق يزداد في
روما
الحكومه الايطاليه اعلنت بالامس حاله
طوارئ لمده سته اشهر وذلك
لمواجهه ازمه موجات طالبي اللجوء المتدفقه
بزياد على حدودها خلال الفتره الاخيره
رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه جورجيا امس قالت
ان اوروبا ربما تواجه خطر وصول موجه ضخمه
من المهاجرين الى شواطئها من شمال افريقيا
عدد المهاجرين الوافدين الى ايطاليا ارتفع
بشكل حاد في الاشهر الاخيره مقارنه
بالفتره ذاتها من العام الماضي على الرغم
من جهود الحكومه الائتلافيه اليمينيه
لتضييق الخناق على طالبي اللجوء
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع تنضم الان الينا من
واشنطن لورن سايبرد الباحثه في قسم حقوق
اللاجئين والمهاجرين في منظمه هيومن رايتس
اهلا بك
بالطبع هو ملف جدا مؤلم
الفاجع في الامر انه رغم ازدياد
قوارب الموت والحوادث المتعلقه بها ورغم
ذلك لا ليس هناك اي انخفاض في وتيره
الفارين او طالبي اللجوء كيف يفسر هذا
هناك عوامل متعدده تدفع الناس لكي يغادروا
البلدان الام وعدد كبير منهم يصلون الى
اوروبا عدد من اللاجئين يحاولون
الوصول الى ابر الامان هناك مناطق مختلفه
متاثره بهذا الوضع
والوضع اصبح اسوا في تونس بالنسبه الى
الاجانب من ذوي البشره السوداء
وطالبي اللجوء وهناك انتهاكات
وضغط عليهم وهذا ما يدفع باعداد مزيد منهم
ليحاولوا المغادره وبالتالي يجب التطرق
الى جذور المشكله التي يعاني منها هؤلاء
ونتحدث هنا في هذا السياق عن المشاكل
الاقتصاديه وظروف الحياه لتدفع الناس
للمغادره وبال الامم المتحده دعت في كثير
من المناسبات لتحسين ظروف معيشه
في قيم من جنوب الصحراء ولكن هل فعلا هذه
الدعوات واقعيه التنفيذ
هناك دعوات كثيره انطلقت من الامم المتحده
من اجل تحسين ظروف معيشيه لهؤلاء الذين
يحاولون اللجوء في في جنوب الصحراء ولكن
لم يحدث شيء ما واقعيه مثل هذه الدعوات
التي تتكرر دائما
هي تتكرر والامم المتحده مؤخرا دعت تونس
للتطرق الى موضوع خطاب الكراهيه الموجه
الى الاجانب وخصوصا الاجانب من ذوي البشره
السوداء باضافه الى الهجمات التي يتعرض
اليها هؤلاء على اساس عرقي وهو مجال يمكن
تونس ان تحسن كثيرا فيه حيث ان نتحدث عن
اجراءات من جانب السلطات ولكن في الوقت
نفسه كان هناك اجراءات وتدابير من جانب
المدنيين والرئيس بدا بهذه الخطابات عندما
ربط بين المهاجرين ومنسوب الجريمه ومحاوله
تغيير
النسيج المجتمع في البلاد وهذا ما ادى الى
موجه من الانتهاكات التي استهدفت
البشره السوداء في تونس وبالتالي هناك
دعوات متكرره في حاله تونس على وجه الخصوص
للرئيس العوده عن هذه التصريحات
والتخفيف من مستوى الانتهاكات الموجهه
باتجاه
للاسف انتهى الوقت شكرا جزيلا
الباحثه في قسم حقوق اللاجئين والمهاجرين
في منظمه
[موسيقى]
نبقى في سياق ازمه طالبي اللجوء فلا
خيارات نموذجيه لديهم في بعض البلدان
يواجهون ملاحقات بل في بعض الاحيان
تصريحات رسميه تعرض حياتهم وحياه ذويهم
للخطر يضطر بعضهم الى العوده من حيث اتوا
بالرغم مما يعنيه ذلك من مخاطر وصعوبات
حياتيه دفعتهم للمغادره اصلا فقد فرح
هؤلاء من بلدان تواجه حروبا ومجاعات
وكوارث انسانيه او انهم مهددون باعمال
انتقاميه البعض الاخر يلجا الى المجهول
املا في مستقبل افضل مجهول ايضا نتحدث عن
رحلات محفوفه بالخطر عبر طرق
عفوا
عبر الطرق واعره وغير مامونه
تنتهي بهم احيانا الى حوادث غرق والقى
العشرات منهم حتفهم هي بلا شك خيارات صعبه
لهذا نختم الحصاد شكرا
[موسيقى]